one time
my mom said I was telling her like what
I wanted to do I was like right out of
high school or still in high school
and I told her I wanted to be a music
video director because back then in the
90s that was all the rage music videos
and when I was telling her I wanted to
go to La and like study film and do all
this stuff and make videos where
musicians she said oh People Like Us
don't make it like that
say we're not successful in that way we
don't make it that far up in life and
that destroyed me that is
totally flattened my
dreams aspirations whatever you want to
call them I internalize it myself up and
it became true here I am but you can't
make it and you could still make it have
you thought about that a lot of work
that's a lot of work I don't want to
maybe that's what she meant we're too
lazy to do that maybe that's what she
meant ultimately she was right